- Today Ebuka opened a new cereal box.
He ate a bowl of the cereal,
which was 8 percent of the
cereal in the entire box.
It Ebuka continues to eat
this much cereal in each bowl,
approximately how many
more bowls of cereal
can he expect to get from this box?
So, when the box is new,
he eats 8 percent of it.
But we're assuming that
he eats that same amount.
So this is the bowl.
So this is his cereal right over here.
On the first day, this
is going to be 8 percent.
When he eats that same
amount the next day,
when he eats that same amount the next day
it's gonna be more than 8 percent.
So this is 8 percent of a new box.
8 percent of a new
of a, of a new,
of a new box.
So how many times can he do that?
How many times can you take
8 percent of that new box?
Well, if the new box is 100 percent,
well how many groups of 8
can you divide that into?
Well, let's just take
100 and divide it by 8.
One way to think about it,
you can just pick a number,
maybe the original box
is some hundred units,
and then on each day he's
gonna eat 8 percent of that.
Which is gonna be 8 units.
And I don't know what the units might be.
It might be milligrams,
or actually it would probably be grams,
or even, or ounces, or
whatever else it might be.
But then you just get 100 divided by 8,
how many servings of 8 can he get
if he starts off with 100?
Well, 100 divided by 8 is, let's see,
12 times 8 is 96.
So it's gonna be 12 and four-eighths,
or 12.5.
So, he's gonna be able to get
approximately 12 and-a-half bowls.